a copper jockey how much you made today  huh 30 cents  45 actually 45 cents huh who's 50 keep  the change of filthy animal  hey Penny Lane I'm talking to you you  know I can't figure out why we take our  best president and put [ __ ] coin this  girl comes up to me right new girl  apparently in charge of making it like  grab a little lunch here with you yeah  have a seat  you heard them so anyways this girl says  she's in charge of the $2 bills right  [Laughter]  hell are you  [Music]  you get the [ __ ] out here  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you keep up with the new clean diamond  so those guys haven't seen him for a  while huh they stopped returning my call  you were kind of a jerk yeah I'm sorry  about that  I really kind of let the responsibility  water under the bridge you know oh don't  worry about it I got it I got it oh no  we don't have any bitcoins yeah we  actually used to work at the moon  together  [Music]